you
[Applause]
feel i have it is my there i am the
bits father has been out a long time ago
and queer and then they go nice get
monastery yes and pain
that bracelet necklace you more fascinating than
pass by here know my skin like blue
now sammy and  javi
escalera
jungle boldie nogami handsome trump
semi-pro hair makeup they
were
poor crowd this is raw this is normal
so me the inner cords
and my cousin griefer like comment and i
'll drop him and down mink was my
faizan you know my stokers  fired and
memory service recently
like some sort of stain on god liesbeth is
never make the press such actually
environments heather hsu okay highcare audi
s6 and sorts this pawn management
[Music]